also ich habe mich sehr geärgert muss
ich sagen über unseren
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach tatsächlich was macht denn
dieser mann muss ich mich da fragen am
montag noch sagt er will die korona
quarantäne regelung freiwillig mache das
man sich kann sie eigenverantwortlich in
quarantäne begibt wenn man infiziert ist
und am dienstag kommt ihm plötzlich
spontan irgendwie geht ihm ein licht auf
und er merkt man halt moment das sendet
irgendwie ein falsches signal und dann
haut er nachts um 2 uhr 30 das muss man
sich mal vorstellen haut er einen tweet
raus wo er sagt ich habe mich geirrt das
ist falsch das machen wir doch nicht das
wird eher kassieren hat er ein paar
stunden vorher bei markus lanz auch
schon gesagt dass konnte markus lanz ja
augenscheinlich auch schon kaum fassen
was er da was er damit erlebt das kann
nicht wahr sein ein gesundheitsminister
der so sprunghaft addiert ein hin und
her minister ist karl lauterbach
mittlerweile geworden und er hat heute
sogar ganz offen bei einer
pressekonferenz auch noch zugegeben ja
wohl er hat bei twitter auch bei social
media reaktionen bekommen die ihn
bewogen haben dieses verfahren wieder zu
ändern dass er selbst am vortag
eigentlich vorgeschlagen hatte das geht
nicht ein hin und her minister ist eine
realsatire dass er unter anderem
aufgrund von talkshow auftritten und
aufgrund seiner drei überhaupt
bundesminister geworden ist dass der
jetzt in einer talkshow und bei twitter
dann eine solche eine solche änderung
irgendwie verkündet das kann doch nicht
wahr sein karl lauterbach das ist eines
bundesministers muss ich leider sagen
unwürdig ein solches vorher bekam ich
kann ich mich ihnen nur anschließen oder
karl lauterbach ist ein schönes beispiel
dass ein klassischer besserwisser wie
wir als kommentatoren sind dann sich zum
notorischen schlechter machen entwickelt
mehr das ist eher der acker karl
lauterbach hatte eine pleiten pech und
pannen serie die die die europaweit
vielleicht von österreichische
gesundheitsminister noch erreicht wird
aber ansonsten fällt mir niemand sein
also der kleinste abstand zwischen zwei
knöpfen ist er mittlerweile ein
lauterbach also wir müssen man muss
einfach anfangen wieder leute die nicht
in jedes mikrofon beißen die vielleicht
vorher mal nachdenken bevor sie ein
interview machen die nicht auch schon
süchtig sind mir kommt ja vor die
tochter sind das kokoschka lauterbach
der braucht das für sein ego für seine
präsenz das sind diese kleinen männer
die haben das oft nötig
klein kleiner laden nicht so klein ich
stadtleben in deinem studie da muss ich
auch als es nicht so klar er ist größer
als ich ich bin auch große natürlich
gewaltig
die
grundgeschichte ist natürlich als
diejenige das mikro wollen wir
weitergeben
dann gebe ich euch die frage an frau
werden was natürlich angesprochen hat
ist da danach twittern ist dieses
verhalten normal so wichtige
entscheidung erst bei markus lanz
darüber zu reden denn um 234 entsteht
und dann soll er auch noch im
gesundheitsausschuss gefehlt haben heute
morgen also es ist natürlich wirklich
eine serie die überhaupt nicht
funktioniert und er hat ja auch
anscheinend ein imperatives mandat
dieses imperative mandat wurde eben mal
von den twitter nutzern gegeben
überhaupt gesundheitsminister zu werden
jetzt wenn man mal die reaktionen auf
seine entschuldigung auf twitter
angeschaut hat da ist ein
spd-bundestagsabgeordneter der twitter
dann ja gut wir hatten eine laute
fraktionssitzung hat also was genutzt
sagt sag mal geht es eigentlich noch
dass jemand aus der eigenen fraktion in
dann auch noch so abschießen öffentlich
und als ich um sechs aufgestanden bin
und gesehen habe 237 habe ich wirklich
gedacht ist der fake account so das ist
ja wirklich schon gut das blaue häkchen
da sind weil wundert sicher ob es
wirklich war und wenn man dann weiß
woher noch in der talkshow und dann mein
ausschuss war direkt neben
gesundheitsausschuss 1000 kameras
aufgebaut warten auf den
bundesgesundheitsminister und ließ
parallel von den kollegen im
gesundheitsausschuss dass er da nicht
auf tut dann ist es wirklich auch
eintritt in das konto von dem
parlamentarismus von allen kolleginnen
und kollegen weil es so toll ist für ihn
ist mit markus lang zu diskutieren er
hat einfach im ausschuss mit den
kolleginnen und kollegen im bundestag zu
diskutieren und das geht gar nicht und
ich finde man braucht auch sie haben es
gerade wichtig gesagt mal das nachdenken
man braucht aber auch mal als politiker
ab und zu sein schlaf und ich würde mir
wünschen wenn ein
bundesgesundheitsminister
der so wichtige entscheidungen wo es um
die gesundheit wo es ums leben der
menschen geht dass er das nicht macht
indem er übernächtigt ist übermüdet ist
und dann irgendwann mal was raus sei das
geht einfach nicht er hat ja mit diesem
lesen von studien hat er sich ja selbst
auch irgendwie ins gespräch gebracht hat
dann heißt es immer ja der liest nacht
standes akribisch diese ganzen studien
ja das macht er vielleicht auch er ließ
da irgendwie rein aber dann liest er da
irgendwas ist schnappt da irgendwas auf
das jagdhaus ich erinnere mich daran wie
ihr irgendwie getwittert hatte vor
einigen monaten da war er noch nicht im
amt als bundesgesundheitsminister ja
kann auch sein dass irgendwie corona
über die klospülung sich ziehen in den
ein also in den mehrfamilienhäusern sich
dann untereinander inzwischen die
wohnung verteilt solche solche
absurditäten das sind da liest er
irgendwas bläst das haus denkt nicht
darüber nach was das dann menschen da
sehr verunsichert sind davon er täte gut
daran jetzt als bundesminister da stimme
ich völlig zu muss man sich anders
verhalten das geht so nicht mehr aber
war das nicht ein spannender prozess
steininger die frage an sie ich fand den
prozess wie karl lauterbach
gesundheitsminister geworden ist sehr
spannend man kennt es ja aus den
parteien beziehen widersprechen wenn ich
jetzt unrecht sage wenn man zum beispiel
in einem kleinen landesverband ist ist
es eigentlich schon mal eher
unwahrscheinlich die große
parteikarriere bis zum minister zu
machen und vielleicht einmal drei
saarländer im kabinett das war auch ein
manchmal gehts aber es geht nicht immer
das ist ja meistens schon auch
parteipolitik oder würden sie mir da
widersprechen der minister wird also so
wie man da steht in der partei und da
fand ich oder sebastian herrscht da fand
ich den weg von herrn lauterbach
spannend als ausnahme beispiel die
partei wollte ihn eigentlich nicht also
die politik wollte ihn eigentlich nicht
und er hatte es über die bürger die ja
übrigens karl lauterbach wollten es war
also eigentlich die du warst nicht sogar
die demokratischste minister
entscheidung dass man sich jetzt nicht
so genau zum einstimmen natürlich zu
stehlen also wenn sie eine regierung
gebildet wird ist es bei vielen so dass
die dann auf einmal als wir bekommen
weil das fenster offen war und dann auf
den ruf hören möchte hat einen da ereilt
bei manchen funktioniert dann bei
manchen nicht am schluss muss man sagen
karl lauterbach den wollte eigentlich
keiner in der spd denn ja weder der olaf
scholz den wollte die fraktionsführung
nicht und wenn wir jetzt den europäern
eben angesprochen auch innerhalb von der
fraktion hat er kein gutes standing und
was hier passiert ist ist das über
empfunden und die twitter community so
ein großer öffentlicher druck aufgebaut
dass lauterbach dann minister werden
sollte und ich erinnere mich noch dass
kevin kühnert angesagt hat ihr wolltet
ihr kritik
und soll das sagen sie wollten ihn dann
und jetzt kriegen sie auch und was ich
sehr spannend auf twitter finden wo ja
auch sehr viele mit sehr radikalen
positionen unterwegs die sind auf einmal
ganz schön enttäuscht von diesem neuen
gesundheitsminister und das sagt halt
auch viel und hat ihn ja getrieben jetzt
in der nacht offensichtlich dass die
leute ihn darüber reaktionen geschickt
haben denen er nicht gerechnet hatte und
dann knickt er davor ein ohne
offensichtlich wussten auch ganz viele
linke enttäuschte feministinnen für die
er wirklich der total erhält auf twitter
war wirklich über monate es war so ihr
gott angebetet haben und dann hatten sie
ihn und jetzt waren es wirklich total
traurige tweets die größte enttäuschung
ihres lebens als ob sie ihr ehemann wer
also es war
es war ja schon bezahlt ja schon bei der
bei der bei der abschaffung der masken
fläche eigentlich aber muss schon sehen
also weder olaf scholz hilft ihm also er
könnte ja die seine richtigen kompetenz
durchsetzen und ihm an der stelle helfen
auch die fdp ein stück war zwingen noch
die spd-fraktion die fdp wie den auch
nicht und jetzt auch noch nicht mal mehr
die twitter-community es wird einsam um
karl lauterbach worauf müssen wir denn
jetzt warten oder bitte nicht jemanden
der bewohner überhaupt nicht aber die
spanier wollten ein schönes
karl lauterbach der beste mann der cdu
in der regierung so zuhört also sie
können da gibt es noch
auf dieser seite
prätorianergarde dieser dieser regierung
ist ist beneidenswert dass er im urlaub
schulz das kaiser soja wäre vielfach
ermordet worden im alten rom aber aber
die geschichte seiner lauterbach zeigt
halt dass man wenn man sich nach
stimmungen auf twitter richtet wenn
twitter a sagt muss man als normaler
politiker automatisch b machen bei
twitter ist immer völlig entfernt von
der normalen volkes meinung also das ist
das der beste indikator die die
links-grüne blase journalisten blase
medien blase auf twitter liegt generell
immer falsch wenn verglichen mit den
mehrheitsverhältnissen bei der
bevölkerung bei wahlen das ist einfach
reziprok argumentieren lassen sie sich
natürlich auch treiben von twitter ich
kann auch immer das gegenteil was habe
ich bei der afg schon gesagt man kann
nicht immer sagen machen die man das
gegenteil von dem was die afg gesagt
oder so dann ist man sich treiben von
diesen leuten man muss schon selbst
überlegen und selbst die programmatik
entwickeln und nicht nur irgendwie
hauptsache dagegen egal ob jetzt gegen
twitter oder die afg zum beispiel dass
das ist mir dann auch so einfach an der
stelle ja aber das stimmt ja völlig aber
das ist ja nur ein indikator bei den
geschichten also dass das ist wenn man
wenn man bürgerlich mitte rechts ist
dann bald man natürlich keine rot-grünen
meinungen in vielen dingen dass das ist
ja das ist ja eine logik so sehr man ja
nicht beides ist man ja bei den grünen
also gott behüte also von den ja ich war
noch lernt man einen diesel und möchte
möchte auch noch meine kinder gut
ausgebildet haben wenn man meine kultur
weiter leben dürfen und nicht grün
ich hoffe ich werde im ganzen bewahrt
also solange die meinen gesunden
menschenverstand und hausverstand noch
das darf man ja heutzutage nicht mehr
sagen hausverstand diese abgeschafft
weil wir sind ja gibt ändert die sind
wir sind ja politisch korrekt und wir
wir dürfen ja heutzutage nicht mehr
sagen was vor 20 jahren war völlig
normal ware war ohne ohne dafür
geprügelt so wären natürlich kann man
sagen aber man hat natürlich massive
nachteile ich habe so ein beispiel zu
nennen eigentlich also hier dürfen sie
alles sagen das reich der freiheit also
das wetter passiert ist kann ich
natürlich auch völlig egal ich vertrete
meine
persönliche meinung ich sage das
klassische beispiel migration dass zum
beispiel wir haben in wien bezirken mit
über 90% pflichtschulbereich
nichtdeutsche muttersprache
das hätte man vor 20 jahren noch locker
sagen können das ist nicht gut das
dickicht der integration dass das sie
kreiert die die deutschsprachigen kinder
das wird aus dem kommt nichts gutes wenn
man das heute sagt dass man
ausländerfeind dann dann ist man gegen
integration dann ist man gegen
multikulti und man gegen dieses dieses
diese neue wunderbare punkt hat die aber
leider dann eine jahre änderungen aus in
wien 25 prozent aller jugendlichen in
der mindestsicherung sind während
gleichzeitig die betriebe händeringend
arbeitskräfte suchen zu dem thema ich
möchte jetzt nicht das wort auch schon
einmal zum thema flüchtlinge kommen wer
noch nach der werbung reicht aber noch
kurz vor der unterbrechung frau
beherrscht einer von ihnen beiden ein
kurzes fazit wenn man jetzt als bürger
darauf warten sollte das karl lauterbach
zurücktreten muss wie viel muss denn
noch passieren dass im bereich des
möglichen liegt fangen sie gerne an und
deinen folgen die frau wäre vielleicht
ein situations fehler in irgendeiner
seiner
meditation schriften oder ist glaube ich
allerdings nicht ich denke nicht dass er
zurücktreten wird in den nächsten wochen
aber es ist schon ziemlich ernst weil er
nämlich die bevölkerung verunsichert
durch solche aktionen und das liegt mir
vor allen dingen am herzen dass wir
dafür öffentlich sorgen und mir wäre es
tatsächlich wichtig dass er häufiger im
gesundheitsausschuss als bei markus lanz
ist ich glaube das hat das land verdient
so ne ganz andere ernsthaftigkeit ich
glaube dass er völlig überfordert ist
dass er das sich ganz anders vorgestellt
hat und es ist eben was anderes auch mit
also es ja auch für die ganzen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
zuständig ist ja auch chef von triesen
behörden das darf man auch nicht
unterschätzen und wenn ich jetzt da
beamtin im gesundheitsministerium wer
würde ich mich auch ärgern dass ich mir
den ganzen tag hier den hintern aufreißt
und arbeite und mein chef hat und nur in
talkshows herum also deswegen bitte
wieder nächste sitzungswoche am mittwoch
gesundheitsausschuss pullover haus da
wird dringender gebraucht den appell
geben wir hier mit einem car lauterbach
weiter